check this out our own nate tanebon the  las vegas aviator is getting a very  special treat from nate tonight he was  there and he had the honor performing  the national anthem at the ballpark take  a listen  [Music]  don't be the people have to audition to  have this uh that honor right i i think  he has just he doesn't like you can't  just roll in yeah i got my flute nate's  audition is he's played it so many times  in the morning show he's pitch perfect  he's got everything he's in key yeah and  he sounds great here's the guarantee  when they got to knights in the national  anthem oh yeah that's right  you've got to keep your confidence  tournament saturday during the national  anthem everyone did the nights there  yeah it's like it's everywhere las vegas  tradition